في الذات الكبد
من لا يتالم لضر يصيبها فكيف بفقدها
يخشى ان الاف الاطفال الاتراك والسوريين
قد قضوا في كارثه الزلزال الامم المتحده
التي تقول ذلك تتوقع ان الحصيله النهائيه
ستكون مرعبه لم يخلو المشهد من لحظات
تبتهج فيها الملايين وتبكي في ان معه
الحمد لله يحدث ان تخرج القلوب الصغيره
خفاقه من تحت الانقاض لكن سرعان ما نواجه
معها حيره السؤال المحتوم عن اليوم التالي
تقدر عموم المتحده ان اكثر من سبعه ملايين
طفل تاثروا بالزلزال بكل من تركيا وسوريا
ففي المحافظات التركيه العشر المتضرره كان
يعيش ما مجموعه اربعه ملايين الف طفل
بينما تشير التقديرات الامميه الى تاثر
مليونين ونصف المليون طفل في سوريا
الاثر باق بالرغم من النجاه الموصوفه في
احاحيين كثيره بالمعجزه
فطفوله هؤلاء تعبر الى محنه جديده تشكلها
الاصابه او الصدمه او فقد الاهل والماوى
او جميعها معها
تقول هذه السيده ان ابنائها باتوا يرددون
ان طفولتهم قد ضاعت
الحقيقه ان معظم الاطفال الناجين من كوارث
مماثله تهزهم في الغالب صدمات نفسيه او
اعراض ما بعد الصدمه
تلقي العلاج النفسي والدعم الفردي
والجماعي قد يكون متاحا للاطفال المتضررين
في تركيا اكثر مما هو بنسبه لاقرانهم في
سوريا
وجه الاختلاف الاخر بين الحالتين مرتبط
بمصير الاطفال الذين كتبت لهم النجاه ولم
تكتب لذويهم
يؤكد نائب الرئيس التركي ان 574 طفلا
انتشلوا من انقاض مباني منهاره وجدوا بدون
اهاليهم ويضيف فؤاد اقطاعي ان 76 منهم فقط
اجتمعوا لاحقا بافراد من عائلاتهم مع ذلك
تبدو الحاله السوريه اشد سوءا فالى اين
يوجه يتامى الزلزال هناك من الاطفال
الى دور الايتام المقتظه في الاساس ام الى
بقيه اهل في بقعه ما من ارض سوريا
شتت الحرب كما نعلم شمل العائلات السوريه
خلال العقد الماضي مما يعقد الان عمليه
العثور على اقرباء للاطفال الناجين من
الزلزال
حتى الناجون مع اهلهم لا يخرجوا سريعا من
دائره المعاناه فالماوي المؤقته لن تغني
عن دفء البيت المفقود
وتقبل العقول الصغيره وضعها الجديد سيحتاج
لبعض الوقت